[Music]
chris
sometimes people in congress and other
places
where there are stupid people believe
that a millionaire
is someone that makes a million dollars
a year in income
that is not the definition not at all
dave and we want to break it down you
want to take
what you own minus what you owe
so that what you own the money in your
bank account the money in your 401k
403 b cars all those things add it up
and subtract out what you owe
on any debt and that net number if that
final number is a million dollars or
more then congratulations
you are an everyday millionaire in a
political season like we have been in
and in a season in this country where
we try to find things we don't like
about each other
division uh we try to find things to
divide up
one of the things that has happened is a
war
on success when i was growing up
you were taught to work hard save your
money be excellent and become successful
now when you do that you're evil yes
yeah you've got a target on your back
and i talk about that in the book and i
think it's a result of this victim
mentality
where it's really easy to try to blame
something or someone
uh if you haven't achieved something and
in reality what it is it's more about
being
intentional it's about personal
responsibility looking inward and owning
it
what you did or what you haven't done
just owning it but then making a
decision that hey
this is my start point this is where i'm
gonna go from now
and so i think if you all listen to the
news and you watch you'll hear this
victim mentality
you'll hear that jealousy that spite
that's coming out
and you know it's a shame because we are
taught to win
yeah instead of i will leave the cave go
kill something and drag it home
right it turns into um
i must take something from someone else
who has earned it yeah
uh because and of course they have to
set up the uh the complete lie that has
been told over and over again
that the vast majority of people with
wealth uh in america
inherited it yeah and uh actual research
not your broke brother-in-law's opinion
actual research says otherwise it really
does it showed us that almost
79 of the millionaires that we studied
we talked over 10 000 of them
right 79 did not inherit a dime these
were all people that were first
generation millionaires by the way
that's 8 out of 10 that's all over
that's all of them
and so you hear this and you go whoa
hold on a minute
they didn't just have something handed
to them these were people that worked
and built it over time
and you guys another five percent got an
inheritance after they were already
millionaires
and another five percent got an
inheritance that was not large enough to
matter
to cause they got five thousand dollars
from their grandma that's right
or something like that so they did
inherit money but so we're we're now up
to
89 of the people that are millionaires
in america
with the largest study ever done
airtight research techniques
shut the crap up we did this right
i'm really not listening to your belly
aching no did not inherit their money
now if you are a millionaire and you did
inherit your money we're not mad at you
because i fully intend for my children
to be millionaires when i die
because i worked hard and left it to
them so that is not evil and it doesn't
make my kids evil no not at all they
were not born on third and thought they
hit a triple
but the key is is to understand it and
we got to chop down these myths
because otherwise people think that
they're excluded from becoming it
because they didn't go to a prestigious
school hear me with this
the student loan debt 1.7 trillion 62
percent of these millionaires went to a
public state university
and you go to some fancy school eight
percent went to a community college
nine percent didn't go to college at all
so college has no prerequisite on what
you do with your money
it's about knowledge